نظمت امس هيئه المسرح والفنون الادائيه في
السعوديه مؤتمر صحفي تم الكشف في عن
تفاصيل العرض المسرحي الغنائي الاول من
نوعه معلقه من امتداد امجاد وهو العمل
اللي بيؤرخ لامجاد المملكه في تسعه عروض
انفعاليات يوم التاسيس اللي بتحتفل فيه
المملكه في 22 فبراير المقبل ان شاء الله
المؤتمر تم بحضور الامير عبد الرحمن بن
مساعد صاحب الفكره والمشرف العام على
المشروع اللي قال ان فكره العمل جاءت له
من سنتين وبتلخص فكرتها بمجارات المعلقات
وكتابه 10 معلقات جديده وطلب من 10 من
اصحابه الشعراء انهم يساعدوا في المشروع
وحضر المؤتمر ايضا صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير احمد بن سلطان بن عبد العزيز ورئيس
التنفيذي الهيئه السلطان البازعي ونائب
المشرف العام المخرج عامر الحمود والمؤتمر
كان مليان باللقطات اللي الناس وقفت عندها
وتداولتها وابرزها كلام جدا عن الملحن
الصادق الشاعر
قريه احمد تكمن في شيء
انه احنا بدينا بالحوارات اللي تمهد
للمعلقات
موسيقي فهد عفت وصادق الشاعر
على شان ما حد يسالني عن صادق الشاعر صادق
الشاعر في المسرحيه هذه انا
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
يعني هو اعطاني دوره في مسرحيه
صدقني
لما تسمع اصوات الاساتذه اللي هناك انا
كموسيقى استحي الحقيقه احط صوتي جنبه
هذا واحد
اثنين
الشغف اللي عند العبد لله
ما هو ان صوته اللي بان الشرف اللي عندي
اني الف لاصوات
جميله
في الواحد
ولذلك قلتها من قبل مراره ان تكرار انا
الشغف اللي عندي هو التاليف الموسيقي وليس
الاداء
وشكرا على الاطراء يعني لكن ما هو والله
شغف
الامير الشاعر عبد الرحمن بن مساعد صاحب
فكره العمل والمشرف علاء اهلا فيك معانا
سمو الامير واول شيخ خليني اقول لك مبروك
لانه احنا تكلمنا سابقا عن هذا المشروع
واعرف قد ايش يعني لك يعني
الله يخليك
يعني
35 سنه
فعمل مهم في غايه الاهميه مثل ما تفضلتي
هو عمل جماعي ما في بطل واحد يعني في
ابطال الكسر
والعمل هو البطل وامل الحقيقه انا ما ابغى
احرقه على الناس انا قلت بعض الاشياء في
المؤتمر الصحفي ولكن نحن امام مسرحيه
شعريه غنائيه
لاول مره في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الخليج بها المستوى الاحترافي العالي
الحقيقه كمان ابغى اقول ساره حاجه همم
يعني همم ما كان ممكن العمل هذا يتم لون
المناخ الفني
والدعم اللي موجود في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
للثقافه والفنون والسياحه والرياضه جميع
العناصر القوه الناعمه الان في دعم كبير
لها من الدوله وفريق رؤيه ولي العهد الله
يحفظه
وجميع قطاعات الدوله تنفذ هذه الرؤيه
باحسن طريقه ممكنه وده شيء لمسته انا من
خلال وزاره الثقافه واخترت لنا الامكانيات
انه عمل بهالحجم وبهل مجهود اللي انعمل
فيه يتناسب مع يكون معه عرض يوازي ما بذل
فيه من جهد هذا ما كان ممكن ممكن
الامكانيات لي وفرت لنا من وزاره الثقافه
ولولا الرؤيا الفذ الولي العهد في كل
المجلات انا
اعتقد انه ال- ال- الفنانين والمبدعين هم
اقدر الناس على التعبير عن حضاره بلادهم
والفنون والثقافه بشكل
اكثر قدره على توصيل حضاره اي بلد واعطاء
فكره حقيقيه
ايش تقصده بهذا الشيء تحديدا
انت لما احنا طبعا عشان تكوني في الصوره
المسج حق العمل او الرساله حق العمل انه
عندنا على فكره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
همم
هي مهبط الوحي هي يعني ارض اللغه العربيه
جميع شعراء المعلقات اللي من 16 قرن
كلهم بدون استثناء الشعراء العشره عاشوا
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه بلوى وصفوا
في معلقاتهم التي خلدت والتي قال كثير من
المؤرخون انها علقت على الكعبه الشريفه
بمكه المكرمه
كلهم وصفوا في معلقاتهم مناطق المملكه
الحضاري المعلقات العربيه وهي شيء قالت ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لهذا السبب
فالحقيقه ان نحنا مهبط الوحي لان احنا
موطن اللغه العربيه
امتدادنا ما هو 300 سنه بس احنا امتدادنا
16 قدم ربطنا المعلقات وجارناها واسقطناها
على
عشره الانظمه وثيقه تاريخيه
وعالجت بشكل ازعم انه كان موفق وان شاء
الله ما اقدر امدح العمل ولكن انا متاكد
انه احنا بدلنا فيه اقصى ما نستطيع من
جورج وكل اللي عمله فيه للامانه قدموا
افضل ما لديهم اتمنى انه هذا ينتج عنه عمل
يرضي المتنقل انا شايف انه بعض الناس
جالسين بيسموه اوبريت وانت مو عاجبك كثير
الموضوع اسمه لا لا لا احنا ابعد ما نكون
على استخدام
بس لانه تعرفين في فرق بين المسرح الشعري
الغنائي وبين الابدين اللي هيجي يتفرج على
العرض من يوم 19 فبراير لانه 28 سييدرك
اننا امام مسرحيه شهريه غنائيه ونحن
امامبريت لوبيريت ما في شيء بالعكس
وبريتات جميله
ولاقت نجاحات وستلاقى لوبريتات القادمه بس
احنا هنا الموضوع
وهذا هيبان للناس ليش اسمها مسرحيه شريره
لانه فيها تمثيل فيها فيها فيها
مشاهد تمثيليه فيها حوارات فيها
الكاتب المسرح همم لصالح زمان
فكره انه انه يخرج شعراء المعلقات ليكونوا
معنا على المسرح بطريقه مبتكره حيث
يشوفونها الناس في الارض احنا مش بس وفيها
حوار شعري غنائي يعني موضوع من ناحيه
الطرح اكد اجزم انه غير مسبوق
جميل جدا واحده من الاشياء اللي كانت
لافته في المؤتمر الصحفي سمو قلت انا في
هذا العمل صادق الشاعر بس بس في هذه العمل
كيف واحد يقدر يعني يكون في عمل واحد صادق
شاعر يعني طبعا صادق الشاعر اللي هو
الملحن المعروف
ساره انت انت الموضوع هذا
وتحققين معايا
واحد طب انا بس والله العظيم عندي بس سؤال
يعني واحد عامل البرواز ملح هذا البرواز
ملحن شبيه الريح ملحن هذه الاعمال الضخمه
كلها ما يبغى يقول انا هذا الملحن والله
شوفي بقول لك على شيء انا ما ابغى احب
يعني العبد لله كشاعر
بشيء اخر فعشان كذا ملاحظ صادق الشاعر
تصادق الشاعر اللي مدخل حلوه الاجابه هذه
لا لازم
الاجابات خلاص والله العظيم
كلنا عارفين انك انت سموك صادق الشاعر
بس الا اذا اخذناها ان السكوت علامه الرضا
[ضحك]
الحقيقه ساره بعيده بعيدا عن
يعني ابغى اشيل الحاجه كمان
اشتغلت في العمل والله العظيم الفنانين
الشباب اللي اشتغلوا الممثلين
بس الحقيقه يعني شوفتها
والله يا ساره
انك غاليه استاذ استاذه واعلاميه
فعلا فخور فيها الى درجه
ممكن تسوي كل شيء نجاح والتوفيق قدر رب
العالمين وماله قتلولج على ما قاموا ولكن
يا رب على قد الجهد اللي عملناه لان احنا
شغالين فعلا في العمل هذا من سنتين يا رب
يطلع على قد الجهد يا رب واحده من الاشياء
يمكن المختلفه جدا الاسامي اللي مختارينا
في العمل نحنا متعودين على اسامي معينه
كبيره دائما موجوده انتم رحتوا في اتجاه
الثاني مختلف تماما بالضبط بالضبط احنا
تعمدنا ذلك
نحن
نحذفكم رؤيه سيدي ولي العهد لدعم الثقافه
والفنون بشكل عام بان احنا قادرين كنا
نحنا يعني بس تخطب الفنانين الكبار
والفنانين الصف الاول حتى من نادي
ولكن يعني طبعا لو كانوا جوف فدادين
وفدانين الصف الاول بالتاكيد كانوا حيعطوا
اضافه عظيمه للعمل هم من هم ويكفي ما
قدموه ولكن احنا تعمدنا انه المشروع تكون
يعني ما في يكون هو البطل مثل ما قلت لانه
انا مثلا لما لما جت الفكره في
البدايه اني استطيع ان يعني انا قادر اني
اكتب النصوص كلها الحقيقه هاكتبها بروعه
اللي كتبوه الاخوان الشعر اللي اللي وصلت
لهم المهمه
يعني صادق
الشعب الجانب ال ال الاغنيه يعني سهم عنده
قدره انه يعمل اغنيه تضرب وبتمه موسيقيه
عاليه لابد من وجوده
نامين الشباب
اللي اختارهم شغ
ف وبعدين بروفات عندنا يعني بدنا من
الاسبوع قاعدين نسوي بروفات يعني الجروبات
الفنانين اللي شغالين معنا اربع اسابيع
وراء جروبات بس شغف هذا كنا نحتاجه وبنفس
الوقت كمان رؤيه سيدي ولي العهد قائمه على
الشباب
يعني ولقيتها فرصه مناسبا يعتبر نفسي من
الشباب برده اكيد طبعا اكيد طبعا شيخ
الشباب كلهم بس هو الامير انا اول شيء
دائما باشكرك على وجودك معي ودايما دايما
بتكون اضافه وبتنورني وان شاء الله دائما
وجهي يكون حلو عليك زي وجهك حلو علي يعني
وان شاء الله
في العربيه اولا في برنامج
الاكثر مرات ومع اعلاميه قذره ومختلفه عن
من سواها مثل ساره
ههه
مصر لاخر لحظه طيب اوكي حاضر اوكي تسلم كل
الشكر وكل التوفيق يا رب ان شاء الله تكسر
الدنيا كان معنا الامير الشاعر عبد الرحمن
بن مساعد صاحب فكره العمل والمشرف عليه
[موسيقى]